[Music]
every cell in our body contains a copy
of our genome over 20,000 genes 3
billion letters of DNA DNA consists of
two strands twisted into a double helix
and held together by a simple pairing
rule a pairs with T and G pairs with C
our genes shape who we are as
individuals and as a species genes also
have profound effects on health and
thanks to advances in DNA sequencing
researchers have identified thousands of
genes that affect our risk of disease to
understand how genes work researchers
need ways to control them changing genes
and living cells is not easy but
recently a new method has been developed
that promises to dramatically improve
our ability to edit the DNA of any
species including humans the CRISPR
method is based on a natural system used
by bacteria to protect themselves from
infection by viruses when the bacterium
detects the presence of virus DNA it
produces two types of short RNA one of
which contains a sequence that matches
that of the invading virus these two
RNAs form a complex with a protein
called caste 9 caste 9 is a nucleus a
type of enzyme that can cut DNA when the
matching sequence known as a guide RNA
finds its target within the viral genome
the caste 9 cuts the target DNA
disabling the virus
over the past few years researchers
studying the system realized that it
could be engineered to cut not just
viral DNA but any DNA sequence at a
precisely chosen location by changing
the guide RNA to match the target and
this can be done not just in a test tube
but also within the nucleus of a living
cell once inside the nucleus the
resulting complex will lock onto a short
sequence known as the pan the cast nine
will unzip the DNA and match it to its
target RNA if the match is complete the
cast 9 will use two tiny molecular
scissors to cut the DNA when this
happens the cell tries to repair the cut
but the repair process is error-prone
leading to mutations that can disable
the gene allowing researchers to
understand its function these mutations
are random but sometimes researchers
need to be more precise for example by
replacing a mutant gene with a healthy
copy this can be done by adding another
piece of DNA that carries the desired
sequence once the CRISPR system has made
a cut this DNA template can pair up with
the cut ends recombining and replacing
the original sequence with the new
version all this can be done in cultured
cells including stem cells that can give
rise to many different cell types it can
also be done in a fertilized egg
allowing the creation of transgenic
animals with targeted mutations
and unlike previous methods CRISPR can
be used to target many genes at once a
big advantage for studying complex human
diseases that are caused not by a single
mutation but by many genes acting
together these methods are being
improved rapidly and will have many
applications in basic research in drug
development in agriculture and perhaps
eventually for treating human patients
with genetic disease
[Music]
[Music]